quelles sont nos chances de survivre 60%
chances de mourir
je prendrai le canapé vous dormirez sur
les toits cela qu'on les marie et
casablanca
ils nous observent embrassez moi
on m'a dit que vous êtes est belle et
doué être doué pour ce genre de travail
n'ont rien de beau
après la guerre vous irez ou quand la
guerre sera finie
peu importe où je serai on s'est trouvés
viens avec moi à londres
viens et devient ma femme
je t'aime de tout mon coeur
il n'y a pas de bonne façon de dire ce
qu'on a à vous dire
on soupçonne votre femme d'être une
espionne allemande cette absurde si vous
avez raison nous n'en parlerons plus
mais si c'est vrai vous la thur et de
vos propres mains
et si vous refusez vous serez pendu dans
72 heures nous serons définitivement
fixé est ce que c'est un jeu un test
tout n'est qu'un test tu étais différend
avec moyens sont différents
comme si tu étais en colère c'est la
mère de mon enfant c'est une erreur et
je le prouverai regarde ses peines vous
avez désobéi aux ordres délibérément tu
me fais peur
quand la guerre sera fait
importe où je serai
et alors où est passé mon baiser